we're talking about this 25 years since
the release of pieces
of you what do you recall most about
that time in your life
gosh i remember
uh
i don't even know how to sum it up um
you know i moved out when i was 15 and i
didn't want to be a statistic i grew up
in an abusive household and i knew kids
like me
you know if you move out especially at
such a young age you can be a statistic
really easily and repeat the cycle
and i didn't want to be a statistic and
three short years later
i was homeless you know i ended up
homeless because i wouldn't have sex
with a boss
and started living in my car because he
wouldn't pay me my for my rim
and then my car got stolen and uh
i just remember it was like this moment
where it was a transformational time
this was either going to
kill me or i was going to learn and i
ended up learning
and making a really honest record i got
discovered while i was homeless and
i almost didn't sign the deal which
sounds really strange
but i had just started figuring out what
happiness was even though i was homeless
and i remember being on the beach and
making myself a promise that my number
one job would always be to figure out
how to be happy
and a whole human not a human full of
holes
and that my number two job would be to
be a musician and
that in my music i would always choose
art over
fame and with those two promises i
decided to go ahead and sign this record
contract and it led me
on a wild ride that is still going today
but the thing i think i'm most proud of
looking back is that moment on the beach
when i made myself those two promises
and that's what i really think about
yeah people talk a lot about the
pitfalls of fame
and how that's at this is important to
keep in mind um
when you went from making that promise
to yourself on the beach to
all of a sudden everybody knowing your
name what was it like getting that
attention was it overwhelming
it was very overwhelming for me and my
personality you know i never thought
that folk record would
be such a massive pop success i was
trying to make a really honest record
like
harvest or harvest moon or like my hero
john prime
and so when it got so big i don't think
i was prepared i don't think anybody can
be prepared
i'm a shy person i'm naturally
introverted i'm definitely a writer
where i like to watch people
so being watched in return to that level
by the time i was on the cover of time
magazine it was overwhelming
you know you couldn't go to the bathroom
without people following you in and
it's just very strange and because of
that first promise i made
you know that i have to figure out how
to be a happy person
i remember taking two years after the
second record
because i couldn't psychologically
absorb what was happening
and then as a writer too i didn't have
enough quiet time to write
and so i decided to re-engage in my
career after my second album but by
taking all the pressure off
because my first record had sold so much
money i realized i didn't ever have to
be famous i didn't even have to make
money again
like this record was like a magic carpet
ride
that you know 14 songs changed the
trajectory of my life and i was like i
get to make whatever music i want
however i want whenever i want and when
i started doing it that way i became
much
happier yeah you know there's something
about um
one thing for music to speak to people
but also for someone's personal story
that speaks so loudly
to people you know the one that you just
told me
and that's when i knew that's what i
remember from when i was young
hearing you for the very first time um
and it really stands out what have you
felt from people that have spoken to you
telling them that your story affected
them or that they
were going through similar circumstances
people have often asked me how can i be
so revealing in my artwork
and it never seemed hard to me because
the only way to truly be safe is to be
very honest that way you're never caught
fame you know a lot of people use famous
propaganda to make themselves seem more
perfect
more talented more beautiful than they
are and it's not the truth and you
always get found out
so for me the way to take the pressure
off was to be very honest about myself
and my fans really embraced that and
you know being a singer-songwriter is
different than being
a singer or a pop star
or even a rock you know star like being
a singer songwriter means you have to
care about people you have to care about
honesty
you know there can only be about three
or four songs about love and the rest
better better be about society and what
we're seeing around us
and it really is this sacred uh
thing you know that bob dylan and neil
young really instilled in me
when i toured with them of what that
means and your relationship with people
um and it's been an incredible
relationship my fan base ended up
calling themselves the everyday angels
from a line in a song of mine called i'm
sensitive and it's just about the fact
that when we're honest with each other
and we help each other we have the power
to work basically miracles and we forget
how much power as individuals we have
and i mean that's an amazing thing to
have a fan base rally around
you know these songs became more than
just like
singles they became part of the
landscape it
comes it almost feels like you just know
them
they just kind of lived in you if you
were you know alive at that time
listening to them how was your
relationship with this music
changed over time and how are you like
what keeps you excited about these songs
now 25 years later
i'm going to do a live stream show on
october
no sorry november 20th and
i'm learning all the songs i'm going to
sing the whole album in sequence i've
never done it before i've never sung all
these songs in one
place like this and so i'm going back
and learning
a lot of these strange open tunings and
these eight minute long songs
and it's like visiting you know friends
uh
and seeing myself now as an artist and
what my art was like
then you know i didn't have any
self-awareness honestly at that time
of what my art was like um and it's neat
it's neat to see
you know my 16 year old self like really
struggling to find a way to express
emotions and
i'm really excited for the show because
singing them in order is really
it's powerful to me like it definitely
makes me cry it's a very
much more cathartic thing than i thought
it would be as well what's standing out
to you about the songs now as you're
relearning them
revisiting them
uh i think what stands out is i can i
can hear what i was reading you know in
alaska i grew up without electricity we
didn't listen to
to music but i read a lot and so a lot
of the russian
writers that were very like
revolutionary you know writing for the
common man this very like
passionate writing and same with a lot
of latin american
poets that i was reading at the time um
i can hear a lot of leonard cohen you
know so i can really hear my
influences and that i didn't have any
rules you know i was writing eight
minute long songs that were like folk
operas
because i didn't know songs had to have
a structure and there's a lot of uh
creative freedom when you don't know the
rules and it definitely made me want to
go back to saying okay i gotta forget
some of the rules
nice are you excited to be able to reach
out to people
the way that you're going to on the 20th
in this livestream is much different
than
you know performing for an audience a
live audience
i'm really excited about the the live
show um there's a beautiful theater in
the town where i live so i'm going to go
in there it's an old theater from the
1900s and we have three cameras and i
wanted it to be like a really beautiful
shoot not like a zoom
concert uh and i'm excited because i
have a lot of fans all over the world
i've never really gotten to see i've
never been to south america
there's lots of countries that i quit
touring a long time ago and so
because it's this pandemic and because
we have to do things virtually i can
actually do something where
australia and everybody can tune in
which i'm very excited about
when we're allowed to travel again would
you reconsider would you
think about going on tour again yeah
yeah i don't know if i'll tour you know
this anniversary i have a new record
coming out
and uh i'd probably tour that um but
we'll see how much i like doing this
you know the sequence of songs from that
first album we'll see
and you've also been very uh vocal about
using your platform promoting
conversations about mental health
including anxiety depression isolation
why why has that been such an important
thing for you
you know we're all we all have this
brain inside this box
and we all have pain but none of us are
taught what to do with pain in school
it's kind of bizarre that realized
everything i was taught in school
didn't actually help me be a happy
person and what's the point what's the
point of being good at math or having a
good job if you're not
happy if you don't know how to handle
stress and anxiety
i think we've lost a lot of those skill
sets and that's what i was most
interested in
because my number one job was to figure
out how to be happy and so i spent a
lifetime accumulating knowledge to help
me gain
tone and mental fitness and emotional
fitness and career fitness
as well as physical fitness nutritional
and parenting fitness we have to gain
educations in this otherwise we feel
really unbalanced and it's not
harmonious
so these tools that i learned when i was
homeless to help solve for my anxiety
they're just little tools that i
invented
and they were actually proven to work by
a neuroscientist named dr judson brewer
to really rewire your brain
and so i started just creating a youth
foundation
where we help at-risk youth using those
tools
a public school curriculum where it's an
english class you know regular core
english class every school has the money
for that
but it has these mindfulness tools built
into it and then right now
i'm starting up there's a festival we
have again with this whole human model
of helping people get education
and then also a culture company for
businesses to help create a culture in a
company that helps
solve for pain and their employees and
make them more productive
that's amazing you know with all that
experience and knowledge and work is
there anything you would go back
in time if you could 25 years and tell
yourself
from what you've learned now i would
definitely tell myself that
being hyper vigilant doesn't help you
win
you know it doesn't even keep you safe
it just keeps you very busy
uh what actually kept me safe was just
not quitting
and i mean emotionally um not not really
with my career although not quitting
there helped too but
stubbornness isn't you know a bad
quality when it comes to
learning how to be happy you just have
to keep saying i'm gonna do something
different today and it's that tenacity
that eventually
will get you there so if i could have
learned to relax and just trust that
process and that with time it would
happen
um that probably would have saved me a
lot of stress it seems like you have so
much going on
are you excited for the holidays would
you take a little bit of time to relax
you know i really love the life i built
there's a song called painters on my
first album of a woman that says
you know i'm painting myself a beautiful
world and
i've always taken that really seriously
i want my life to be my best work of art
i don't want my art to be my best art if
my art is my best work of art i'm kind
of an
a-hole i think i want the whole thing to
be
thoughtful and that takes time but
creating a sculpture out of your life
and so i'm not
i'm busy but i'm also a lot of time
quiet i don't tour that often
um i do things i'm passionate about and
it's constantly finding that way to have
permission to say no i get to make this
how i want what do i want it takes a lot
of
introspection but um i'm not tired i
used to be you know i burnt myself out
with my career and it's not like that
anymore um
so i will take time for the holidays but
i'm really happy that i'm being very
productive but not in a way that
exhausts me now and that's a huge change
for me
you